so my name is Wally I'm the technical
lead for the Android window manager and
activity manager today I'm going to be
presenting what we're doing in and to
support multi window mode it's going to
be relatively short presentation mainly
because I want to give you all a chance
at the end to ask any questions you may
have relating to your a specific use
case in multi window mode okay
so multi window mode allows multiple
activities to be visible on screen at
the same time the activities are
resizable from the full-screen area down
to a minimum size allowed by the system
or activity in the end we're going to be
supporting three forms of multi window
mode split screen mode window mode where
two activities are visible side by side
and the dividing the middle can be used
to give more or less screen space to one
activity or the other picture-in-picture
multi window mode where an activity is
zero that always on top of all of the
activities on-screen and free for multi
window mode where multiple activities
are visible on screen at the same time
they can be moved around freely and also
resize to any arbitrary dimension so
some important in the end to keep in
mind right on the Android activity
lifecycle model is not going to be
changing in multi window mode we're
still only going to have one resumed
activity in this system at a time and
all other visible activities are going
to be in the post visible States on
there several reasons we are keeping
this model on Android right and what the
main reason is you know being in the
regime States is an important indicator
to the system on what resources and
activity can acquire because it's kind
of as the is you know important score
for example right the the camera service
discovery singleton resource right and
the resumed activity is always going to
get that resource compared to all other
activities during the fall States
another important thing to notice that
we are now also factoring in the low
memory score adjustment of visible
activities
deposit using LZ order for those of you
that don't know the law no Scott just
non-android is basically an important
score given to all processes in the
system the higher your score the more
important you are to the system and the
motor system will try to keep you alive
and when this system is running low on
resources right it kills things that are
of lower importance call fest alright so
for example you can have a seven shiny
background right and you cannot be
resumed activity and the system when is
running long resources would here this
is service running the program affairs
before the resumed activity that is a
might be interacting with so similar for
for visible activities and apostate
right we kind of rank them in order of
the SEO of the right and give them a an
appropriate low memory score adjustments
so if the system is really really
running long memory and it needs to kill
visible tivities it's going to start
from the only one with the law as the
other first however when the system does
that i we do preserve the coins window
on screen so i still visible to the user
right and we apply dimly on top of it
once the user interacts with the app
again right we then bring it back to
life something else that is important to
note is that as of n since it is in
desirable for video apps to stop video
playback one day and apostate the new
recommendation s of n is for videos to
and who play pause actions in on stat on
stop versus on resume on pause well it
has always been the case in android that
a pause activity can still be visible it
has not been as visible to the user as
to be with more to window right so it's
it's a message with now pushing forward
a little bit strongly note that on what
the various life cycle stage represents
right when you're waiting on stats it
means you're going to be visible soon or
resume means you're visible both and
focus on pause means you're still
visible but not focus and on stop means
you're no longer visible
so I'm not attentive to notice that as
the user resizes Europe in multi window
mode we do ensure configuration changes
however we only limit this configuration
changes to configurations that will
cause new resources to be loading you up
so for example if Europe has two buckets
where it has a layer representation for
portrait and one for for landscape right
and as the user resizes Europe right in
portrait mode if they are not crossing
it treasure deposited each orientation
right we do not issue new configuration
changes or Kostya has to relaunch right
however once they cross that
configuration threshold right and new
resources need to be loaded we do
reissue the configuration change for
landscape mode it's also important to
note that on the configuration change am
referring to year only applies to the
activity on screen another overall
device configuration so the device can
be in landscape mode while your activity
in multi window mode can be in portrait
mode also as you do today you can
continue to undo configuration changes
to avoid relaunches in order to avoid
relaunch ends in multi window mode you
need to enter all the configurations I
have on screen screen size smaller
screen size screen layout on orientation
on if you choose not to undo the
configuration changes you will be
relaunching resizing however we do
preserve your current window on screen
until you render new content into a new
window and we replace it seamlessly and
so that the experience of the user is
not jarring and appears as smooth as
possible so there are several new
appears were going to be introducing in
the end to better support multi window
mode I'm going to be going over a few of
this api's
so the big one is the resizable activity
manifest attribute on this is an
attribute is said to indicate to the
system that your activity supports
multi-window and can be researched when
the ability dimension or in sports you
note that we enabled is that activity by
default for all apps including the ones
not targeting in right and you need to
explicitly target in and set it to false
in order to disable note that we
recommend that there for all up another
important it to notice that the the
route activity of a task determines the
recess ability of that task you can
think of a task as every single card
entries in the recent activity over the
activity right so if the route activity
is marked as resizable any additional
activity that goes in that task is also
resizable however if the route activity
isn't resizable then no other activity
in that task detached will not be
resized right so another activity and
that task would be resize as well
another cool new appear we are having is
the launcher just an API with the launch
HSN flag you can launch an activity I
just sent to yourself while in
split-screen mode to window a mode for
example of on screen the chrome activity
on one side with an address link and
implementation could be done where once
you click on that address link the map
activity is launched adjacent to the
chrome activity so an activity can also
use the layout style able mostly in free
for multi window mode to set its initial
or default launching position and size
on screen you can settings like your
default height which gravity whether you
want to be on top center bottom right
and what the minimum dimensions you
allow the user to resize your
application to
so in multi window mode right as the
user resizes your activity right the
layout of your app can be slow depending
on your implementation right so what
Israel would notice is kind of an effect
way they perform an action and the other
way here right and Europe is still kind
of taking time to relay out to catch up
to the user action that experience is
not too desirable right so what we're
actually doing in N is we introduce a
second UI thread in the application
process to draw a background color that
keeps in line with the user action as
the main apps UI thread takes time to
render content to catch up with to the
user action you can use the window
background style able to customize what
this polloi is so picture-in-picture
mode on while it's desirable for most
apps to support picture and big
disappointment window mode it doesn't
make sense for all apps and supports
picture and picture modem motor window
for example you would expect an app like
Netflix or YouTube to support picture
and picture mode right but you didn't
expect an app like Google Docs to
support picture in picture mode so to
differentiate this form of multi window
mode we have the supports picture and
picture mode on manifest attribute for
the app to indicate that I can go into
this mode with apps are this flat set
right on devices that support picture
and picture mode they can call the enter
picture and picture mode API to put
themselves into picture in picture mode
a few things to keep in mind with the
with picture picture and picture mode is
even though the activity is the order on
top of all other activities in the
system right it is actually in the
paused visible States right and the
activity that is fullscreen below the
picture and picture activity is actually
in the resume state and the main reason
for doing this is once the user puts
your activity into picture and picture
mode right they really want to watch
your activity to decide right while
interacting with the with the fostering
activity so it makes sense for the
activity to be focused and resumed why
your activity is in the visible spa
State it's also important to keep in
mind that you can contain
to use the media session ApS we have to
the right from white and
picture-in-picture mode to keep track of
you know media buttons like play pause
actions and whatnot um we also have our
ApS allow you to to get notified
whenever the system or Israel puts into
multi window mode or whenever you exit
multi window mode and picture-in-picture
mode and you can also query the system
on your clients window a mode in
freeform mode
um activities are allowed to display
content next to the UM caption slash
tied to a area using the overlay with
the caption API you can kind of think
about the chrome tabs you have on your
computer right where you come tap on
next to the window control buttons with
this API you can kind of do something
similar
also in freeform mode an activity can
launch another activity at a specific
location and size on screen using the
activity option set launch bounce API so
currently on Android we support several
PS right they affect the entire screen
configuration right you can think of the
navbar status bar customisation for
example right and this customization for
the entire screen would would have
conflict in multi window mode especially
when apps request conflicting
configuration so to that effect right we
have most of these configurations
disabled when the apps and multi window
mode as some of the examples listed on
screen like the system UI customization
for steroids by nappa right sure what
paper behind immersive mode and setting
orientation something important to know
with setting orientation right once you
say your app is compatible multi window
mode right
having a fixed orientation doesn't
really make sense in our world anymore
since the user can kind of resize you up
to any dimension and it can change
orientation while changing that
dimension so it can make sense for that
to be disabled regardless of the
conflict in my tab
so some new expects practices and
guidelines for multi window mode include
on your provided single responsive UI
for your for your application so the
user as a consistent experience why
using your application on the same
device at different sizes on your cell
by designing your app for the most
challenging you scale so you can uncover
architectural problems early in the
design process on your father the
material design pattern so that your app
as a consistent look and feel which
other apps running on the system right
and we you want to only disable multi
window mode when justified it's to be
awed if most apps on the user device
going to multi window mode right and
your app is the odd one out and is the
launches right and it wanders into full
screen mode and look for various places
to take advantage of all the aps were
exposing for multi window mode like the
launcher just Android for appropriate
use cases
so some more guidelines and best
practices we recommend that as with
similar layer for phones and tablets may
use the phone tablet on on I'm sorry the
phone UI on tablets right
since the experience will not be true
during to the user as they transition
from one side to another IRA for also a
completely different layout right we
recommend that the phone UI shouldn't be
used right instead the tablet UI should
be made to work at a smaller size right
and scaling off from there and the main
reason for these recommendations are
guidelines is to kind of give the user a
consistent feel and experience as they
resize your activity in the same device
so to simplify adapting your app for
multi window mode what we found is it's
better to design your app for this
smaller size first alright if you can
get something working with 220 DP wide
at all right you can by convention
elements or moving on and session ones
then you can basically scale up you know
your apps you sketch from there
everything's as you as needed um a nice
complementary feature to multi window
mode is the system-wide drag and drop
API with the Android drag and drop
framework you can allow activities to
share data using the graphical drag and
drop gesture on some of the basic API
for drag and drop include star drag and
drop of that drug sure the drag sugar is
really the term there what you see when
you actually dragon and cancel drag and
drop pretty cool API okay so I said it's
gonna be a short presentation and I just
like to end by saying the android
framework right we've done a whole lot
of walking into our multi window mode
and to make sure the aps we feel will be
useful to our developers and the UI as
supported at the platform level right
however that's just half the work right
we really depend on the app developers
right to
stop picking off this feature up in the
end preview to start using it
testing out Europe makes you sty
performs unless out correctly right and
resize they see what come problems you
come up with and providing us feedback
on things we can improve any platform to
make your life easier right it's kind of
it's just out there for two to get this
feature to a level where it really
brings joy to the to all Android users
everywhere as they as they use multi
window mode so yeah so that's all I have
a representation are some useful link
links up on screen right and there are
mics on on or they always if you want to
ask any questions on the topic thank you